では そろそろ始まりましょうか
はい それから雰囲気を作るということについて
仏教の話  ちょっと違うということも覚えておいた方がいいと思います
相手に合わせて雰囲気を盛り上げるのではなく
調和を保ちつつ正しいことを選ぶ
今まで私は言ったのはもう相手に合わせなさいというぐらいのね
で 仏教はそんなことは言ってないんです
あれは側変で 世の中でそういうことになってます
はい で お釈迦様の一つ経典を紹介します
で 道理は仲間を作るという
同じ人々はグループ仲間を作るんだと
似た者同士で 性格的に似た者同士は仲間を作って一緒に行動するのだというブッダの言葉があります
で ダートソービッカーウェサッターサンサンダンティサメンティ
このダートっていうのは
この まあなんか本来持ってる性格というものなんですね
それが合う人々は仲がいいんですよ
例えば 怠け者は怠け者で仲間を作る
勉強嫌いなグループは勉強嫌いなグループを作る
勉強好きな人は勉強好きな人のグループを作るんです
だから似た者が一緒になっちゃうんですね
で ヒーナーディムッティカーヒーナーディムッティケーヒサッディンサンサンダティ
劣っているものは劣っているものと一致する気が合う
これ劣ってると書いてあっても
ヒーナアディムッティカっていうのは
もうなんて言いますかね
まあ嫌なことしか興味ない
盗むことやら怠けることやら
もう頑張らないことやら
遊ぶことやら まあもう賭け事やら
そういうもう嫌なことにはえらい興味がある
そうすると 自分の周りに何のことなく同じグループが出来上がっちゃうんです
はい 次 すぐ早く終わります
セイヤタアピビッカヴェーグートーグーテーナ
ムッタームッテーナサンサンダティサメーティケーローケーレーナサンダンタティサメーティプッボープッベーナサンサンダティサメーティローヒタンローヒテーナサンサンダティサメーティ
エオメオコウティ また文章長いんです
例えば比丘たちよ グートっていうのは
あの便のことを 便のことですね
便は便と一緒になるんだと
誰も便はね 皿に入れて食卓に置こうとはしないでしょうに
同じところに流しちゃうんですね
それでムッタームッテーナ
尿だったらまあ誰もガラスに入れて飲もうとはしないし
それは尿のあるところに流しちゃうんです
それからケーローケーレーナ
ケーラっていうのは唾ですね
唾は唾と一緒になるんだと
プッボープッボーナ 海は海と一緒になるんだと
そういうふうなことで劣っている人々は劣っている人の間で仲間を作るんだと
これも波長の問題で波長がいいんですよ
波長が合ってるんです
だからそこで雰囲気は盛り上がるんですよ
だから 例えばもう まあ何でもね
例えばまあ盗賊したい人々がいるんだったらね
もうまた泥棒の仲間になっちゃうんです
そこで泥棒をする 何人か集めたら結構雰囲気が盛り上がるんです
自慢話までして これこれやったとかね
はい それでカルヤーナアディムッティカー
カルヤーナアディムッティケーナサンサンダンティサメンティ
で あ 訳書いてないんだ
訳は忘れちゃった で カルヤーナアディムッティカっていうのは良いことを好きな人
勉強は好きとかね 努力するのは好きとか
で 心を清らかにすることは好きとか
そこを目指している人々はカルヤーナムッディ
カルヤーナアディムッティケーナ
また同じ人々とよくうまく合うんだと
セイヤタアピビッカヴェーキーランキーレーナ
例えば比丘たちよ キーランキーレーナ
牛乳というか乳とかね
それはもう例えば牛の乳も
何ですか？ヤギの乳も何のことなく一緒にすることできるんですよ
うまく一緒になるんです
ただ入れればいいということで
だから父というものは
どんな父とも一緒になっちゃうんですね
いとも簡単に テーランテーレーの油は油とよく合うでしょうに
皆様 ドレッシングというものはサラダにかけるでしょうね
あれは酢やら油やら合わないでしょうに
だからかける前に一生懸命振っておかないと
振っても合わないんです
別々です しかし油入れちゃうと
サラダ油にまたごま油入れちゃうと
どちらがごま油 どちらがサラダ油か分からなくなるんです
一緒になるんです またたくさんあったんですけど
全部省略しました そういうふうに良い人は良い人と気が合うんだよと
それで次の問題は雰囲気を盛り上げるべきかという
今まで散々言ったのに
雰囲気を盛り上げる そのやる必要あるのかと
悪の不善の波動を期待している場合は
その雰囲気を盛り上げると自分も悪に染まってしまうのです
でしょ 例えば 日本の政府はもう戦争することには賛成だと
そちらは悪人同士でいいんだけど
こちらも国民として盛り上げなくちゃいけないということになったらどうなるんですか？やっぱり日本国民は日本政府決めたことを盛り上げなくちゃいけない
で 自分たちの首相を盛り上げちゃうと
イラクで死ぬ死ぬ一人一人の殺人の罪が自分にもかかってくるんです
自分で見たこともないし
行ったこともないのに
だから悪いことを盛り上げちゃうとひどい目に遭いますよ
その場では盛り上がりますよ
みんな褒めてくれます
しかし 自分が罪を犯したことになっているんです
例えば もう 4人グループがいて
銀行強盗をしようとと話しているところに自分が行く
で 自分もしょうがないんだから
あ そうか 面白いことを考えるんですねとかね
結構勇気ありますねとか
うまくいけばいいでしょうとかね
そんなふうなことを言って盛り上げてあげるとどうなるかというと
自分も強盗した罪になっているんです
これは法律とは関係ないんです
心の問題だから だから悪い雰囲気に悪い波動を期待している人に
応援してはいけないんです
泣きたくてたまらん人は泣かすとかね
怒りたくてたまらん人は怒らすとかね
よくないっていうのは
よくないのは自分が罪を犯すことになるんです
だから一緒に泣きましょうという話
日本ではなんとなく なんて言いますかね
それは随分なんかいいことやと思ってるでしょうに
一つもいいことはいいことだと思ってないんだから
悪いことだけあえて選んで
すごいいいことやと人が
泣いているところに行って一緒に泣いてあげるとか
人が恨んでいるところにいて一緒に恨んであげるとか
私はあんまり日本のこと知らないんですけど
テレビソースしかニュースソースしか知らないんですけど
その場合でもやっぱりテレビの連中が行って
やっぱりもう人が誰か殺されてものすごく恨んでいると
どんどんそちらに油かけるんですね
憎いでしょうとかね そこでテレビを見ている我々にも同じ憎しみを与えようとしているんです
私はもう別に影響を受けない人間ですけど
まあそれでも目に入るんだから
チャンネル変えて漫画チャンネルにする
相手もさらに悪事をすることになるので
そんなことで悪いことをするグループを盛り上げてあげると
さらにその人々もいい気になって元気を出して悪いことをするんです
したがって人格は堕落するのです
このような環境から逃げる
離れることを推薦する
ブッダは だから どこを行っても自分が雰囲気を盛り上げるいい人やというふうなことはどうでもいいんです
逃げなさいよと 悪い環境から
悪い雰囲気から 悪い波動を受けたくて受信しようとしている人々から逃げた方がいいと
仲良くする必要もないんです
だからいつでも雰囲気を盛り上げるということはいいということには決してなりません
これは仏教の世界では
はい もうそろそろ終わりと思います
今日は仏教の話はすごい短いんです
少々の薪でも森を燃やせるんですよ
だから森はすごい大きいかもしれませんだけど
ちょっとの火をつけちゃうと全部燃えてしまうかもしれませんよ
これは気をつけた方がいいんです
サンスガワナトジャトアサンサッゲーナチッジャティパリッタンダールマーユマーロイハヤタシーデーマハンナウェーエワンクシータマーガッマサドゥジーヴィーピシード
ティタスマータンパリバッジャイヤクシータンヒーナヴィーリヤンという比丘たちに
お釈迦様が自分の弟子たちを回らなくちゃあかんのだから
仏教のブッダを信じる人々は
在家であろうが出家であろうが関係なく
お釈迦様は随分真剣に守ってあげようと思っているんです
ですから 厳しい指導はするんです
サンスクアっていうのは
そういうお互いに仲良くして絡み合って生活することなんですよ
そういうことから傷が生じるだけやと
みんなと仲良くしようと思っても
この波長が合わないでしょうに
波長が合わないと傷つくんですよ
例えば自分がもうもうなんか友達がもう異性の友達が出て
随分いい気分でいる いい人を見つかりましたと
そこで友達にも言う あ
あの あの女か あの遊び女でしょと言った途端
私が傷つくでしょうに
だから仲良くすることで
ものすごい我々は心に傷つくんです
絡まないと治る 心は治るんです
これ  1行の意味なんです
2行目はパリッタンダールマーロイハヤタシーデーマハンナウェ
この大海に入ったところで
例えば遭難したとしましょう
そこでもう死んじゃうでしょうね
そこでちょっとした板切れを見つけて
それにかかっちゃうんです
ほんのちょっとの板切れあったっても頼りになりません
体重を支えるぐらいのものがなければ
そこでその人は沈んで死ぬんですよ
で そういうことだから
エワンクシータマーガム
これは修行するお坊さんたちに言うんですよ
だから怠け者と合わせるなよと
怠け者に合わせること合わせると良い人も沈むんです
怠け者がいる その人は怠けたいんだから
こいつは頑張りますよという話にならないでしょ
例えば自分が勉強している
もう誰かがゲームやろうとしてくる
じゃああなたゲームやってください
私は勉強するぞってことにならないんです
だから自分が勉強をやめて一緒にゲームやらなくちゃいけないんです
で 何時間になるかわからないでしょ
だから自分の時間は勉強もできなくなっちゃう
そんな感じで怠け者と付き合っちゃうと
もういくら立派な人でもかなり沈んでしまうんです
従って励まない怠け者を避けるべきなのです
タスマータンパリバッジャイヤ
離れなさいよと 悪い波動の人から雰囲気盛り上げるんじゃないんです
クシータンヒーナヴィーリヤ
怠けて努力しない人から離れなさいよというのはブッダの教えなんです
だから良い雰囲気だったら
そこで仲良くする それでこの人間
誰と付き合うのかと前説明したんだけど
同じ経典なんです だからそんな心配することがないんですよ
自分の仲間を見たら どんな性格かすぐわかるんです
自分も 気に入ってる人としか付き合わないんだから
簡単でしょ だから自分の仲間で雰囲気を盛り上げればいいでしょうに
それっていうのは同じ気持ちでいるんだから
そんな難しい問題じゃないんですよ
この観念的に あの雰囲気を盛り上げたい
上司の人になりたい 達人になりたいっていうのも
あまりにも観念的で妄想なんです
そんなのは要りません
どうしても自分には仲間がいるでしょうに
その仲間っていうのは
一応気が合ってるんだから仲間なんです
だからだいたいは波長は合ってるんです
だから雰囲気を盛り上げるということは
そんな難しいことじゃない
例えば友達同士で別に何もしないでしょうに
ただ一緒にいて楽しいだけでしょうに
それは波長が合ってるんだからなんです
そういうわけで 自分の性格に合わない人は
やっぱりそんなに仲良くしようとすることは推薦できない
なぜかというと これは排他的な教えじゃないんですよ
自分が弱いんですよ 送信するし受信するでしょうに
それからまた このもうあまりにもバンドが広くて
もう調整していないでしょう
適切なチャネルしか入らないようにと
だから自分で自分を守るしかないんです
だから我々弱いんだから
もう悪い人も仲間になってしまいいいんじゃないかって
一人二人ぐらいと思っても
やっぱり人間関係できないんですよ
自分は悪くならない限りは
そういうわけで離れなさいと言っているんです
要するに 悟った人は離れるわけじゃないんです
悟った人は影響を受けませんだから大胆に言うんです
だからお釈迦様は大量に人を殺したアングリマーラのところに堂々と行ったんです
一人で 王様も怖くて行かなかったんです
軍隊を持っていくことも怖かったんです
あの人が叫んだら もうもう馬も牛も馬も象ももうもう音を垂らしちゃうんです
震えちゃって だから 増大で言っても
馬体で言っても意味がないんです
殺されます 一人の人間に
そんな凶暴な人のところでお釈迦様は堂々と一人で行くんです
向こうの影響を受けないんだから
微妙にでも怖いとか殺されたら困るっていうことはまるっきりないんだから
向こうに何もできないんですよ
それで だってアングリマーラがもう殺すぞというばっかり出していて
キリするもんかという態度を
お釈迦様はそういう一方的に強烈にその波動を出しているでしょうに
あまりにも圧倒されちゃって
もう手も足も出ないんです
とにかくお釈迦様と一緒に走ることさえもできなかったんだから
お釈迦様は走ったわけでもないんだ
歩いただけ  この人走っても走っても一か所なんです
で 疲れ果てちゃって負けたと
それでいい加減やめなさいと
人殺しなんて言っただけで
わかりました やめます
で 終わり ですから この悟った人は人を害いたしません
でも 我々の場合は気をつけないと
はい 仏教的な雰囲気作り
おだてる 褒めるのではなく
慈しみを持つ 前言ったでしょ
俗世間だったらおだてると
で 似ていますけど 似てない
同じじゃない 仏教では人を慈しむんですよ
みんな人間でしょ みんな生命でしょ
みんな苦しんで生きてるでしょうに
みんな煩悩があるんだから間違いも起こすでしょうし
それであなたが悪い あなたはいいやという言えたところじゃないんだと
自分も同じ人間だから
いろいろ間違ったところもいっぱいあるんだからということで
まあ人に低迷に対して優しさでいる
その時も非難することはできなくなっちゃうんです
それによって相手を非難する気持ちが消え
認めることができる そこで人の高慢を
例えば私が正しいということを認めるわけじゃないんです
仏教は 人は認めるんですけど
これ正しいんだから認めるんではなくて
生命は平等だから みんなどんな生命でもだらしないんだから
まあしょうがないんじゃないかなということで認めることなんです
だから前の側辺で言ったことはほとんど罪に入るんですが
こちら言ってることは全部善行為で素晴らしい修行なんです
自分がおだてに乗らないこと
謙虚でいる おだてに乗ったということは
やっぱり自分が正しいという
ああいう弱みがあって
弱みがあって餌を食ったことになっちゃうんです
釣り餌を だからまあそこは気をつけるんです
だから謙虚なと 別にそんなことそうかっていうことで聞き流しちゃえばいいんです
あるいはそう簡単に褒めるなよと
わからないんだよと言えばいいんです
私はもっと悪いんだと
あんた知らないだけだよと
じゃあ言えばもうそれでなかなかこの人はおだてに乗らないということはわかるんです
向こうも 同時に この人言うことを聞かなくちゃあかんと
信頼できるとともなるんです
それから悪いことから
不善から身を引く どこにでも八方美人みたいにどこにでも仲良くするんじゃなくて
やっぱり自分を堕落する
自分を悪くする 自分の成長を妨げる雰囲気からはもう離れた方がいいんです
身を引いた方がいいんです
はい 非難されても 自分にそれほど勇気がないと身を引く勇気を持つ
例えば万引きしようと仲間が言う
それはだいたい子供の世界の話なんですけど
そこで弱い子供っていうのは
もうお前腰抜けでしょ
弱いでしょと言うと えっ
そうじゃないぞと胸を張って一緒に行って万引きしちゃうんです
それで結局は自分が悪いことをしたことになるんです
その時は堂々と そうそう
私は腰抜け 私は弱い 私は怖い
だから頼まないでくれと
私は震えますよ そんなことやっちゃうと
怖くて怖くて だからお前本当に腰抜けや
腰抜けだから腰抜けで言ってるでしょうにと
そうやって自分が弱いと認めてあげるんです
それが勇気なんですよ
みんな勇気がないんだから
腰抜けだから お前怖いですと言ったら
何言うんですかと じゃあやってやろうではないかという
もう弱いものももういいところなんです
それが あれこそが弱いんですよ
ではやってやろうではないかと胸張ることは
そうそう 私は弱い 私はそんな強くはない
父親に怒られるのはものすごく怖い
母に怒られるのはものすごい怖い
先生にバレるのはものすごい怖い
だからやりませんと ということこそ本物の勇気なんです
だから その勇気を持ってほしい
正しいこと 良いことを論理的に相手に諭す
で 自分が正しい仏教的な人間だから正しいことをやっている
嘘もつかないし 盗みもしないし
無駄話もしないしでしょうね
噂も言わないしというね
怒ったりもしないとかね
生き方をしている それが正しいと相手に教えてあげればいいんです
そうすると相手は何言うかと言うかもしれませんよ
そんなことこの世の中で通じるもんかと
でも気にする必要はないんです
仏教は真理を語っているから
負けてしまう心配は要りません
例えば私は嘘つきませんよと
よくないんだいと あのね
そんなこと言っても この世の中で嘘をつかないと生きていられませんよと言うでしょうね
ああそう ではみんな互いに嘘をついて騙し合えばいいでしょと言えばそれだけでしょうね
私もあなたに嘘で騙されても騙せばいいでしょ
じゃあ見てみろと 気がつかない時はあんたを騙すぞと言うと本人が嫌がるんですよ
だからほら 見てください
嘘はよくないんだよと言えばいいでしょうに
だからブッダが言うことはすべて真理だから
全然人を説得することには不安感じる必要はないんです
どうどうで言っちゃえばいいんです
反応しちゃうとすぐ繰り返して裏返してみせれば
同じことを極端に私はその手段でやっているでしょうに
何でも極端に大きくして言うでしょうに
極端に大きくして裏返してあげればすぐわかるんです
それから常に愛語を語る
やっぱり喋る場合は人が聞いているんだから
人の気に障る言葉は喋らない方がいいんです
意義があるものを語る
それから無駄話ではなくて
あ 聞いてよかったというものを喋った方がいいんですよ
そうすると人々はすぐ受信体制に入るんですよ
あ 聞いてよかったということばっかり喋る人が来る時は
みんなたちまちもう受信体制に入るんです
その人に波長を合わせているので
もう雰囲気が盛り上がっているんです
何のこともなく だから我々はもうちょっと理性を使って
頭を使って 人が聞いてよかった
いい情報だ いいことを教えてもらったという気分になることを喋ってみてください
立派な雰囲気を盛り上がる
良い方向に盛り上がる人間になります
自分の心を穏やかに保つ
それからこの貪瞋痴の感情でしょ
あの雰囲気を電波を送信するのは
それだから自分が穏やかにいると
自分が送信する電波は全部立派なんです
そこを受ける 受ける人も波長を合わせている人は受けるんだから
結構立派な人々は自分の仲間になるんです
例えば 欲の感情で送信しちゃうと
欲ばっかしに絡んでいる人々しか仲間にならないんですよ
だから悪循環になる もともと悪人であった自分がもっと仲間も作って
同じ悪人たちでさらに落ち込む
悪に陥ってしまいます
だから心を穏やかにしていると
自分が何か電波を発信する
その発信する電波も綺麗なんです
そうするとそれは受信する人々もいるんです
受信する人々も大体似ている波長ですよ
それで何とかとかもない
すごい立派な仲間が出来上がっているんです
どうせ仲間っていうのは同類だからね
出来上がるんだから 悪循環は破られて善循環になるんです
どんどん良い方向へ行くんです
正しい生き方をしているのだ
間違いを犯してないのだと自信を持つ
自分の生き方に自信を持たなくちゃいけない
それにはね もっと真面目に生きてもらわないとね
今の生き方では自信を持てないならば
自信を持てる生き方に変えてもらわないと
ブッダが推薦する雰囲気を作る人にはなりません
だから遅くないんです
人生は 気づいた時点で正しい生き方をすればいいんです
それで 私は正しい生き方をしているんだぞと自分で自信を持てばいい
その自信より喜びと充実感を感じる
それで自分一人で喜べばいいんです
なかなか自分が頑張っているんだと
そうすると喜びの感情が出てくるんです
そこから送信するんです
波動 この感情は正しい影響力の強い波動を発信する
そういう喜びと充実感が入っちゃうと
自分がものすごい強い影響力の
それから正しい電波を
波動を発信するんです
すべてそうやってオートモードになるんです
皆 自分を頼りにする その人は頼りにするんですよ
模範にすることになってしまうのです
だから 人が自分を模範にしているんだったら
それ自体が影響力でしょうに
それ自体でも雰囲気を作っているでしょうに
だから悪い 即席のやり方よりは簡単です
また罪も犯さないんです
仏教徒はブッダから法から専有からしか雰囲気を受信しないのです
仏教徒というのは あの人もこう言った
この人も言ったと そこから述べる馬鹿者の話にはあまり耳も傾けないし
影響も受けないんです
ブッダから受信するんです
あるいはブッダの教えから受信するんです
あるいは禅宗 自分より先輩
修行している人々 そういう人々から受信しようとするんです
そこら中によるみんなから受信しようということは良くない
そこでちゃんとチャネルを合わせるんです
受けないということにするのです
はい で 終わり で そういうことで
仏教的な雰囲気作りはそういうことで
それでお釈迦様はもう一言葉言っておいたんです
この悪いものは悪いものと一緒になるんだということは
昔も今もこれからも同じだよと
良い人々は良い人々と一緒になるということは
昔も今もこれからも同じだよという断言的な言葉なんです
だからブッダの真理はこれからも変わりません
だから今説明した雰囲気の作り方も
ブッダのやり方をやれば
もうすばりと成功するんです
悪い人々とはもう縁を切るということと
心を穏やかに保って で
影響力の人間になる というやり方で
以上です どうもありがとうございます
これも選んだのは これは酔っ払って人を壊しに行った象なんです
ブッダのエピソードがあるんです
デーヴァダッタがナーラギリという象に酒飲んで飲ませて飲ませて
それからものすごく怒らせて
いろいろもうもうもう殴ったり
いろんな痛み分けたりして
象がもうものすごいクンクン怒ってしまったんです
怒ってしまって 鎖を破って街に出たんです
ちょうどお釈迦様が托鉢に出る時
見て計算してそう街に追い出したんです
これで王様の象軍隊の第 １ なんです
すっごい立派な象なんです
それから体力も力もある
そこではみるみるものを壊しながら
この象が走っていたんです
みんな人間逃げたんです
もう来ないと そうっていうのは怒ったら結構楽しいんです
何でも壊す だからまあ
やっぱり象は立派ですからね
怒らないんですよ そう簡単に
滅多なことがない限りは
とにかくその象がそうやってもうもうものを壊して壊していくと
もうお釈迦様は托鉢に出ていくんですよ
アナンダ尊者がもう前に出て
ブッダを守ろうとしたんですけど
お釈迦様なんてあんた下がりなさいよと
ただ愛情だけでは物事はうまくいくわけじゃないんです
アナンダ尊者はお釈迦様の代わりに自分の命を差し上げたかったんです
そこで象がアナンダ尊者を殺している間
お釈迦様はどこか行けばいいでしょうに
ブッダは今 今世界の大統領の方々
方々 総理大臣の方々と違うんです
ボディーガードにあたって
その人々はもうブレットの的になって本人は守ってあげるというね
それはやりません 自分が守らなくちゃいかんだからね
例えばアメリカの大統領はアメリカの国民を守らなくちゃいけないのに
アメリカ国民がその人を守ってあげなくちゃいけないんだよ
あべこべですけど それはお釈迦様の場合はないんだ
だから アーナンダ あんた下がりなさいと
で そこはお釈迦様とお釈迦様の波動っていうのは
もうもう一方的に送るだけのことだから
だから そういう まあもうお釈迦様はその扱いは知ってるし
で 名前で呼んで そうっていうのは自分の名前をものすごい覚えているんです
だからもう まあまあ落ち着け
じゃあなんでそんなもうみっともないと言ったんです
みっともないとお前はと
それでお釈迦様の前で跪いて礼をしたんです
で 人々は隠れて見ていたんですけど
これは奇跡的な出来事
物事を壊してザーッと言った僧が
お釈迦様の前でガチンと止まって跪いて礼をしたんだから
お釈迦様は頭を触ってね
まあいい子にしなさいと
もう言った場面なんです
で それっきり その僧も怒ったことはないんです
で そういうことだから
やっぱり偉大なる人の影響というかね
波動は受信するんです
それで我々も立派な人間にはなります
誰の波動も受信する必要はないっていうのは仏教の結論なんです
従うならば善人に従えと
批判を気にするならば
知識人の批判を気にしなさいと
賢者の批判を気にしなさいと
俗世間の言ってる批判というのは気にする必要はないし
というのは まあ仏教の生き方です
はい ではどうもありがとうございます
皆さん